say I still definitely have a ways to go
uh but I'm working on it yeah I mean I'm
open with audience I'm I made a lot of
mistakes now I got really lucky and I
landed with the husband and the baby and
I had a baby late but I'm trying to like
warn women it does it doesn't always go
that way and there's a lot that can go
wrong in the Paradigm if you're
following like bury your head in the
work and you know you want a family but
you don't prioritize that until you're
30. what do you think is first of all do
the women that come to your show do you
think they believe what they're saying
I think sometimes as women we don't even
like realize what we're saying isn't
true
like you think they have that like
moment where they're like did I just and
then they wear it into me before yeah
where okay I'll say like okay the
cheating thing you know damn well that
and like I just use NBA players because
they're so like it's just easy to use
them as an example you know damn well
that a man in Tiger Woods position let's
use Tiger Woods even even my father who
is a great guy he would have a hard time
if there was a Bus full of models
waiting for him every day some guys are
nerds they kind of avoid those
situations but by even even you know and
I would say any guy any guy is gonna
have a hard time if these girls are
sitting at home trying to you know his
wife mouths off after work he's like you
know what just this one day
and you know even me like saying that
and like an intuitive level I kind of
knew that but I was like what no no my
dad doesn't cheeks we got trigger
trigger so and what is that do you think
because I think that emotion happens it
is emotion but there is so much
programming that goes on like even you
know me I sat here and you know my whole
career I'm like defending masculinity
and defending men and do believe in the
traditional family I didn't have a
prince who was passed I never went that
route so I'm sitting here thinking like
oh feminism didn't get me but then I
watched an amputate video about
self-defense and I'm like you know so it
it gets you even if you don't realize it
so I'm wondering like how many women
have this like programming and they
don't really realize it and it takes
like a lot of self-reflection really to
sit back and say wow did this really
make me happy is that good advice like
why am I so mad and that was what I had
to realize with my volleyball career I
was like oh my gosh that probably was a
poor choice and it's hard because I love
like I love I could if I could do
anything in life even before the party
I'd be a volleyball player if there was
money in women's sports why do you say
it was bad choice then because it was
like I spent that was all I did that was
all I cared about and I would say you
know on the on the plus side it avoid
like a lot of bad situations like I
avoided because I was just like
volleyball volleyball volleyball but you
know
um it wasn't really smart to like
prioritize that when there's no future
in it you know is it hard for you with
the values that you have right now to be
in the dating world like do you think
that women who espouse how you feel
about life do you think they have a hard
time
given you know how many women are
willing to sleep around and do this and
do that is it hard
um does it feel challenging for you
I mean yeah I think if it wasn't
challenging I'd be married right yeah
kind of the outcome I don't know how
picky you are one never does know you
know you might have that long list like
some of the girls here now I mean I
think I think about all they gotta be
good look and I was thinking about this
I was like being tall it like makes it a
lot harder for sure dude okay I have to
a moment with the audience too
Pearl walked in now everyone knows I'm
like a small person like I'm I look like
you know the Wizard of Oz and Munchkins
that's me but I walked in I was like
what you were like you got like super
model height yeah no I'm not real I
would say if there's one thing that's
held me back in dating it is the height
I would think so oh my gosh yeah now is
that because you want a guy taller it's
me it's my fault yeah no I'd actually
say I'd go down to like 5 10 I'd say
like an introduction but you can't then
you wear the heels though you're taller
no that's fine I don't mind I'm wearing
heels but I'm just like being honest you
know and maybe maybe that's too picky I
don't know but um I would say that's
probably like if I had to pick one thing
the height that makes it a lot harder so
what I find when I when I cover these
panels yours sometimes we showcase here
is that women are so they don't realize
how picky they are you know they'll say
like oh I'm not picky I'm just looking
for a nice guy and then it's like the
list is a mile long it's like Santa
scroll it unfolds gotta make a certain
amount of money you gotta be this height
you gotta do you have this car and this
house and this job and so it's just like
what what is that always the case well
what's gone on that women are so picky
or is it just like a lack of
self-awareness I mean I think it's like
natural to us like we I mean all right
if you take our mating strategy down to
the roots it's to get the best possible
mate actually I don't mind women being
picky I just think it's like do you
deserve it right yeah well that's it
what do you bringing 250 pounds Rebecca
you're 250 pounds what do you mean you
mean the guy that makes six figures
right you're two and then they get to
the 300 ones they're even more picky
yeah it's like what yeah I saw you had a
an exchange with somebody that wanted I
don't remember what the ring was the
cost was asking oh my God that was a red
pill moment for me that was that was
early that was early it was before the
channel took off I did it I covered it I
couldn't believe it I found it I said
she was talking like she deserved and
I'm always like you know what do you
bring to the table as a female I say
like to women you can't just demand all
this stuff and then say well you know
you I give this you know what what does
that mean you know what are you bringing
to a guy and then if you ask them you
know hey do you want to keep a nice home
they get insulted or hey do you you know
maybe you're a little overweight do you
care about you can't say that you can't
you can't ask them to step up and in any
way it seems why
oh gosh well I just think like from from
a young age we've been told that we're
princesses and queens and we deserve to
be treated like that that's true you're
an average chick why do you deserve to
be treated like that
you slept with the whole football team
why on Earth let me treat you like a
queen like and so it's like
um yeah I just think from a young age
well-meaning fathers oftentimes like
deluded our standards I haven't seen in
the church oh my gosh were you are you
religious I'm calf I went to Catholic
School oh my gosh me too okay okay I
need to know if we had the same Catholic
School experience okay let's go because
I've always been in Pearl you know I've
been maybe more a blue pilled Pearl
right but I've always had opinions and I
remember thinking okay
in the Catholic did you have Chastity
speakers no oh you didn't have that
capacity oh yeah yeah okay okay this is
just a pearl experience so they they
bring in you know how there's like sex
ed in public schools yeah we didn't have
sex side we had Chastity speakers that's
why when everyone's like we need sex
then and I'm like okay I didn't do
in high school so I don't know what like
I didn't need sex dad to know so you're
like you need Chastity speakers yeah
yeah but I remember there was like a guy
and a girl that came in it's like
Christina or something and Jason Everett
chat can find it and they came in
it's like the girl that's been ran
through okay and her husband that was
the Virgin until he was married when
you're red pill you're like oh my God
and it's like you you know you can't
even absorb that just like yeah and so
she would talk about she was so broke
like it was the same message right and I
appreciate that same message but the
message in the church is like they at
the end of the day there will be a
prince waiting for you no matter what
you do no matter what you do and that's
why I was like when the guys are like
the girls are worse than the church I'm
like well this is why yeah because they
say at the end of at the end of your
whatever they'll still be a guy waiting
for you that might not be the case
Rebecca no I'm curious though because
you brought up Catholic School like what
because we're you know quite a bit apart
in terms of age but what was it like for
you to be in school like in terms of
were there a lot of girls who were
promiscuous because when I went to
school there was like there were girls
who did that but you could like identify
it was like this one over here this one
over here they had a reputation and a
bad one and all the guys like knew who
they were could we could we Define
promiscuous because that sleeps around
okay what is so then we go into like
what is sleep surround as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible